hi there today we'll look at tasks
stability
architecture and compute training more
effective learned optimizers and using
them to train
themselves by luke metz nero maez
varanatan
see daniel friedman ben poole and yasha
sol dixteen
so on a high level this paper deals with
sort of a meta problem it deals with
learning
optimizers that learn machine learning
models learned optimizers is a
kind of a new field of research and the
goal is to obtain an
optimization function that can be used
to train
all kinds of machine learning models and
this paper
builds on a line of research and kind of
extends that research it doesn't it's
not the first one
to do this but it is so far the
largest and most compute intensive and
most uh task encompassing uh
notion of learned optimizers and the
optimizer
they end up with has some nice
properties as they're gonna show
and also it can be used to
train itself so it can iteratively
be used to train itself ending up with a
even better learned optimizer so we're
gonna
go through the paper and we're gonna
find out how much of these claims
are kind of um wishful thinking
and how much are actually true i have
mixed feelings about this paper
though in all of this uh remember my
opinion is my opinion
and they are very open about their
results which is something i
really really appreciate i feel that if
more papers were as
open as these people are about what
worked and also what didn't work
we would be in a in a better place as a
research community
that being said as i said i do have some
mixed feelings about the
statements being made here and about how
the results are interpreted
so stick around if you're interested
into that
also i find the broader impact statement
to be a bit
funny but i will come to that at the
very end
if you like content like this as always
don't hesitate to
share it out i've been on a bit of a
break it feels good to be
back making videos after after right
paper deadlines
let's dive in they say much
as replacing hand design features with
learned functions
has revolutionized how we solve
perceptual tasks we believe
learned algorithms will transform how we
trained
how we train models so lots of
packings in this sentence for those for
you young kids
that have been growing up with deep
learning there was a time before deep
learning
and basically what we would do is we
would use hand design features
and this works really well if you have
like a database of customer data
it worked moderately well if you have
like a picture so if you have a picture
whatever of your cat what people used to
do
is they used to run these kind of very
handcrafted detectors feature extractors
over this
um so these might be like fixed filters
like three by three sobel filters
gradient
filters and so on run them over the
image try to to detect corners try to
detect
very small things and then once they had
a couple of features
like this they would feed this into a
classic
kind of classification algorithm like a
logistic regression
and so on there were sophisticated
approaches but most
required the hand engineering of
features
of course deep learning transformed all
of this
deep learning basically if you want to
take a cynical look at deep learning
it's simply replacing the part that
creates the features
the classifier is still like a logistic
regression
however deep learning knows how itself
can extract good features in fact
better features than humans ever could
for perceptual tasks so for images
for sound uh in the latest iterations
also for
language these people say
that this can also this kind of thinking
can also be applied to
this optimization algorithms so in
optimization
what you want to do is you want to train
your deep network right
whatever goes from your image
from this thing right here to your final
output
you want to train this and we train this
using gradient descent
so what this has is usually there's like
many many layers in your deep neural
network and each one
has parameters well let's call them
theta theta 1 theta 2
and so on these are all vectors or
matrices your convolutional filters
your batch norm parameters and so on we
can collect
all of these into a big parameter vector
let's call that
theta and the uh
the task is now to find the best theta i
think you're introduced to that so
in optimization what you want to do is
you
have a theta you feed an x you feed an
example through it
you get some sort of output let's call
that f
that gives you some sort of loss you
back propagate that loss
and what you end up with is a gradient
of theta
if we were just doing gradient descent
we would update theta right here we
would update theta
to be theta minus the gradient
of theta given some step size right here
this is classic gradient descent and
most algorithms are something like this
in for example gradient descent with
momentum
considers has like some additional term
right here
where they consider the last steps at a
grad
for example considers a factor down here
where they divide
by some kind of the square norm of past
gradient
so d sorry
this you add up the past
gradient square norms like this or you
average over them
there are many variants you can do this
averaging right here also with momentum
in kind of a
decaying way there are
all sorts of algorithms to optimize
these functions
and the sense behind this is that
ultimately deep learning
is a non-convex problem so instead of
your classic classifiers they look
something like
this as a loss function in your
parameters or more
maybe more to say something like this if
we look at it in 2d
and you can just do gradient descent
basically
go to the optimum however in deep
learning
it's a bit of a different situation so
you might have many
different optima many local optima and
we know by now that we
can go to either one of them and that
should be fine
so let's do some level sets right here
maybe
here here okay but
so you can see right here you have
multiple optima where these dots are
but in between it's kind of uh shaky so
you might have like a major flat
area right here but then as you get
close to this optimum maybe the
steepness increases so if you look at a
cross section there might be like some
sort of a flat area and then
uh it increases again and you want an
optimization algorithm to kind of
automatically adjust
to the steepness and to changes in
steepness and so on
and that's what these modifications to
gradient descent are supposed to do
so adegrad for example adjusts
automatically to a landscape like this
so even if it's convex you can see that
the scale
of this parameter is much flatter
than of this parameter at a grad would
automatically kind of
stretch one out and make the other
smaller such that it transforms it to a
nice
kind of all the all dimensions are equal
problem because you only have one
learning rate per dimension
if you go further and go into the
regimes of atom or rms prop these now
can also
kind of change over time add a grad also
to a degree but
much more so these other algorithms can
adapt to like
changes in steepness and once it goes
flat again they can kind of recognize ah
now it's flat again so i might do some
bigger steps
once it goes steep again they're like
okay i should probably
be kind of concerned right here there's
also this notion of momentum
that's really useful uh the kind of
counters counter stochasticity
of stochastic gradient descent it's it's
a big field but what they all have in
common
it's humans sitting down coming up with
this particular
like a particular formula because they
feel uh if i you know
do this thing then it might it might do
this it might stretch out these
dimensions that might be beneficial
these are humans sitting down
now the analogy here that these people
make
is we used to do this for classifiers we
used to hand design features that we
felt
make sense like the image gradients and
so on or the fft
for let's say for um sound
and and that um that worked
so far but it worked better when we let
deep learning do
its thing and the goal of course here is
also that we let machine learning
come up with the optimization procedure
so what exactly
goes so if we try to update theta
we might update it not as a fixed
formula
but we might take the old theta we might
take the gradient of theta
and we might take a bunch of features
that we calculate from these things like
things like the sum over the norm of old
gradients
and so on and we put this all into a big
function so f and f
as you know in the classic sense that's
what the humans define but now the goal
of course is to learn
f so we have a set of meta parameters
let's call them
whatever that thing is um
and and and phi
maybe psi i know psi let's call it like
this
and now i have a meta parameters so
let's use let's let's parameterize
f as a neural network that learns to
output the next
weight for the underlying neural network
now the f itself of course
has to be learned somehow but the idea
is is kind of since it's a meta
algorithm meta algorithms tend to be
much more general and much more smooth
and therefore they themselves could be
optimized
fairly generally and once we have a good
f
we can apply it to all sorts of tasks
and that's exactly
what they do so they consider three
problems in
learning optimizers so first of all
computational
scale learning optimizers is hard and
this paper here
invests a lot of compute into learning
one
meta optimizer second
training tasks and this i feel this is
the
kind of the the core here in that what
they do is they
they now you have to pay attention so
if we talk about data sets it's it's
very
confusing now because on one hand you
have data sets like
mnist and you have data sets like
c410 right so these are data sets but
in the in the task of learning an
optimizer
a data set is something like this
um so in mnist let's just make the
analogy here we have
following samples this image
this image uh this image
right in c410 we have like this airplane
right here this is an airplane it's an
airplane believe me
um with the truck right
truck and so on we have this
now this are the classic data sets
however in this paper a data set
consists of the following and this data
set they use here is called
task set so
one sample in the task set data set
is i take the mnist
data set i use like a five
layer cnn on amnest
and um i use a batch size of
32 and i let it run for 10k
steps and so on that's
one sample right the next sample
could be i take c410
i use a resnet 50 on it
my batch size is 64 and i let it run
for 50k steps
right so this this these are now samples
in this task set data set and the task
set data set consists of a
wide variety of tasks i believe
over 6 000 different samples
which include things like rnn
tasks image recognition tasks very
simple like 2d
optimization or sorry quadratic
optimization tasks
and so on so there's all these kind of
different tasks and the goal
you cannot see now the goal is that if
we
find so here what's the goal when we
learn
mnist what the goal is if our output is
going to be
a cnn that we can input any sort of
digit into
and it gives us the label 2. the goal
here in task set is if we find
f an optimizer that works for all of
these
samples in the data set then we can give
any sort of new sample
so let's say we will give we'll have a
new problem right we'll have our medical
medical data set and
um we have this resnet 101 that we want
to train on it
not a pre-trained but that we want to
train on it we want to train it with a
batch size of 64 and so on
we can input that and the um
the optimizer will spit out good
parameters
for that particular uh date for that
resnet 101. the optimizer will be good
so it's important to stress that we are
looking for
one single optimizer um
one single function that can optimize
all these kinds of different tasks
right uh that's a challenge of course
and that's what this paper attempts
and then the last thing here they say is
the inductive bias of optimizer
architecture the parameterization of the
learned optimizer and the task
information fed to it
strongly affect performance in this work
we propose a new hierarchical
learned optimizer architecture that
incorporates additional task information
such as validation loss
and show that it outperforms the
previous learned optimizer architectures
so i think you get the overview right
now so let's actually
jump um right in
so what does their optimizer look like
their optimizer here is kind of the
contrast to previous work
let's actually jump jump into their
optimizer their optimizer consists of
each parameter is associated with one
lstm
and one feed-forward network okay so
the lstm gets the following um
actually let's let's look at the the
feed forward network
where do they say what these output at
some point they say what they output
um one second
nope nope so
here
uh such as training loss validation loss
normalized have a relatively consistent
scale to compute
here to compute the weight update the
per parameter mlp
outputs two values a and b which are
used to update inner parameters
so their formula to obtain this is what
we call theta right here
their formula their formula to update
theta is
this thing right here x a of a
and b so for each parameter
their optimizers outputs a and b
so that's this feedforward network it
doesn't actually
um as i can tell this paper is very
confusing like there are multiple points
where it's
not clear what they do and their
notation
differences doesn't help so here if i
had to guess
i would say they don't output delta w
they actually output
a and b okay
so into their feed forward network goes
the most
important thing is the gradient okay if
if this network were to
do something very trivial it would
simply output the gradient
right here it would it would make a
equal to
what one no what's x of one no that
doesn't work
zero sorry it would output a equal to
zero
and b equal to the gradient and then you
just get gradient descent back
but we also want to feed it with
information that it could use
right that it could use to um to make
better decisions
such as momentum right now
if it can it could technically reproduce
sgd
with momentum if we give it the second
moment
well now it can it can do things like
add a grad because that uses the second
moment
it's no notice like note that
this algorithm doesn't do it
symbolically there are other papers
that try to come up with a symbolic
expression for a better optimizer right
like i've shown you with atom
like you can write it down as a symbolic
expression this is not that paper this
paper
really the output of the feed forward
network is
a number or two numbers per parameter or
two vectors whatever you
you want to look at it like this is a
numerical
procedure you're really trying to for
this thing is this f
it's really a vector goes in and a
vector
goes out okay and these are the features
gradient momentum second moment and so
on um
there are more features that go into the
model
namely training and validation loss so
since you are training an underlying
model
you have access to the labels at all
time
this is what you have to think even at
test time
so when you test your f with a test
task that test sample
will have an associated training data
set
with it right and you're going to
have the loss of that training data set
and you're also going to have the
validation loss um i guess you could
split it yourself if you wanted to
but uh the goal that's
we're going to come how we exactly
optimize f and what the loss for us is
but intuitively
you want to train your f such that the
validation loss of the inner task is as
small as possible
and we're going to see how that works so
yeah the tensor shape
as well so it could technically do
something like implicit batch norm right
it could do that
um depending on how big the current
tensor is that it optimizes
gradient norm and so on so the total
norm of the total gradient
they just feed all this kind of
information in here
and you can already see kind of my first
my first bummer with this is that
if this were really modeled after
classic deep learning
what you would input is two things
okay maybe like the the current step no
not even that
so what you would input is two things
you would input your sample
x and you would input the gradient okay
like you would input your your sorry not
the
sample you would input the current
weight
yes the w that you're changing and you
would input the gradient
which is the gradient that you get from
back prop
from the underlying system and
this technically since the lstm
goes over time right so in each step the
lstm technically remembers the last
steps
if this is a neural network it's a
universal function approximator it could
technically calculate
the momentum it could technically
calculate the second moment
of these things um i guess these things
here
you you could feed in i agree
couldn't do that conceivably but these
other things
you could you know this it could
calculate this
so we're back into the business of
feature engineering
and this is going to and they say this
at the beginning right as i said this
paper is
quite honest they say that these things
that they feed in
also these things they make a lot
in terms of the final performance of
this model
so this kind of bugs itself with the
analogy
of hey remember when we replaced
handcrafted features
with learned features in computer vision
let's do the same
it's only halfway there as yes we are
replacing the symbolic
operation but we are still inputting
a lot of the handcrafted features that
we think are useful
okay so as you can see there's an lstm
going
over the time steps and for each for
each parameter there is a
small feed forward network the output of
the feed forward network
is going to be sent back to the next
step of the lstm
the lstm of course is recurrent and so
on
so i hope you can see how this works
so what this what this does is is
um you have a neural network
that you input a data set into you let a
data set
run through it it gives you a loss and
you are using f to optimize
that loss right f
is a function that takes in the w of
the current neural network that's the w
here and it outputs the w
at the next step t plus one
you do this for a bunch of steps so a
bunch of steps
until you have like i don't know n steps
then you take your validation data set
of the inner task your validation
data set and you calculate your final
loss
loss of your validation data set
um given w so loss given w
of the validation data this is
disconnected right here
and what you want is you want to
optimize
the psi of the f such that test loss
is as small as possible i hope you can
see the problem in this
even if this is all differentiable which
it can be right
you are going to have to back propagate
through
n inner steps of optimization since each
of these steps
is a forward propagation through f right
and only at the end
you have an actual loss right here a
validation loss
so you're going to have to back prop
through all these n steps
which is simply not possible currently
we can't back prop
through thousands of steps and we need
thousands of steps currently
to optimize deep learning architectures
so they are opting for something
different okay
so we have this model the model is
acting as an optimizer at the end
there's a validation loss
and we are wondering how should we
optimize this model to make the
validation loss
as small as possible a given an n step
roll out of the underlying thing while
we can't back propagate through the
entire rollout
and if you have guest reinforcement
learning you're almost
correct so the answer here is going to
be
evolution strategies
they say it right here
we deal with these issues by using
derivative free optimization
specifically evolutionary strategies to
minimize the
outer loss obviating the need to compute
derivatives
through the unrolled optimization
process
previous work has used unrolled
derivatives and was thus limited to
short numbers of unrolled steps yada
yada
using evolution strategies we are able
to
cons to use considerably longer on roles
okay so they they use these evolution
strategies and later these persistent
evolution strategies
which are modifications so evolution
strategies really briefly there are many
many variants of it
but ultimately what you can do is
you are here with your guess of the best
parameters
you are going to perturb these
parameters by a little bit
um in multiple directions so since
evolution kind of the the um there are
many ways of evolutionary strategies and
this
i feel what they do here is sort of the
weakest way
because i've i've had people
uh flame me before because they're
saying like these are not really
evolution strategies and i agree
it's basically glorified random search
so you kind of perturb it
in each direction where you end up with
this population
then you evaluate each of these new data
points and maybe you'll find that
this one this one this one these are
actually good
this is like meh and these ones are
really bad
okay or like worse so you want to
shift your guess of the best parameters
into the direction of the
of the good ones and away from the
direction of the bad ones
and you can kind of see this green thing
here
as a pseudo pseudo gradient
it's kind of a finite difference method
if you really think about it
and i know evolutionary strategies and
so on they contain things like
crossover and whatnot inspired by
biology
honestly they don't say much here but i
have read the um
the kind of other papers or i've not
fully read them but looked at them
and it looks to me like that they're
doing something like this
and they're using kind of the same trick
to calculate this pseudo gradient as
the reinforce algorithm so this is kind
of the
log derivative trick to differentiate
something that is not differentiable
and uh yeah so
again this is not really written well
because
here i would expect that they just take
a step into the direction of these good
perturbed points but what it seems like
just from the abstract because in the
abstract they say oh we optimize
all our things using adam right and
so in terms of the outer grade i can
actually show you
uh this is so here is a again not to
uh rag on these maybe i'm just a poor
reader
but this is a wildly confusing paper to
read and
i have still have not really a clue
what's going on
uh because things are just described
vaguely
then there's this pseudo code which
doesn't help
like it it does not help i like it just
it basically just specifies how they
named their variables
uh it doesn't show you most of the
actually important logic at least that's
what i feel
um okay so here outer optimization
details
we optimize all models with atom right
we swept the learning rates yada yada we
find the optimal learning rate
is very sensitive and changes uh
depending
on how long the outer training occurs
so it clearly they say outer training
and adam which means they use adam for
the outer training
but before they say oh we use derivative
derivative-free methods
like evolution strategies and they
don't say anything about atom up here so
what i'm guessing is that they use the
evolution strategies
to find these pseudo gradients
right here because in the paper that
i've looked up from them
which is their own older work that
they use these evolution strategies to
obtain a gradient
and then i'm going to guess they take
this gradient
right here and they feed that as the
task gradient into atom
and then they use atom to to basically
optimize
their their outer thing but instead of
backpropping to get the gradient they
use es to get the gradient
i'm guessing that's what's happening um
yeah so that for that
then task distributions as we said they
have
this task data set
6000 tasks designed after this task set
data set it's not exactly task set i
think it's inspired by task set
these tasks include rnn cnn's masked
auto regressive flows
fully connected networks language
modeling various variational auto
encoders simple 2d
test functions radicals and more
for tasks that require them we
additionally sample a data set batch
size network architecture initialization
scheme so there are multiple issues here
one issue is that right next sentence to
keep outer training efficient we ensure
that all tasks take
less than 100 milliseconds per training
step
um for each task that makes use of a
data set we will create four splits to
prevent data leakage this is very cool
that they
you know really separate inner training
inner validation outer training outer
validation and so on
um sorry not outer training outer
validation and then outer test
that they only look at at the end of
course outer training
is the inner task but
you can see that even google research
has it doesn't have really enough
compute here to
really thoroughly survey deep learning
as a
field and and take all the tasks into
consideration so they
have to like settle for rather small
tasks like
c410 mnist and so on and various
small architectures of course that go
along with it and if you know
much about deep learning you know that
there are
considerable effects of scale in these
things
namely optimization
has i think optimization honestly has
kind of gone back a step
in terms of complexity it used to be
much more of a
debate like should you know this
optimization algorithm that one
now most people use atom and also a lot
of people just use sgd
with momentum and especially in the
larger models
like let's say bert or or even larger
models
um sgd with momentum seems to be
the way to go not only because it's it's
easy to implement but because it
actually
performs well especially in large
models with large data so there are
considerable effects of scale and by
only training on
small models and data that
is a very big hindrance and we're going
to see it in the results
right after writing the next step right
here
that this this is limited
to that this is limited to that
let's say to that domain they also say
up here unfortunately directly utilizing
these large scale models is
computationally infeasible
therefore we out to train on proxy tasks
for speed
yeah not not really representative in
terms of
how optimization interacts with the task
um the the the yeah so that's
that's kind of my my comment right here
and
one that i see like the biggest weakness
of this paper uh okay
so we went after that and i would say
we jump now into the results so the
results
here are uh the following so here they
compare
with various handcrafted optimizers
right
and it's it's a bit of a
weird thing to um and let me just say
this
this task is a very big and very uh
very hard engineering tasks because all
of these tasks have to implement them
then their loss are of different scales
you have to take care of that and so on
so this is considerable engineering
effort and
uh it's like i don't i don't want to
diss the work i just
uh kind of want to point out where the
limits are
uh in terms of where they might not have
pointed it out so much
so here they compare to different things
uh the top ones
are algorithms that have like a fixed
learning rate it's like whatever in for
adam like i suggest
your three e minus four if that doesn't
work
uh at least a little bit you're screwed
right so
you take that so one trial um then you
might want to
use adam but you might want to kind of
search over the learning rate so they do
14 trials
to search over for a good learning rate
in adam and it goes on
until like this this here is 2
000 trials trying out different
parameter
combinations while their optimizer
their learned optimizer only ever has
one
trial because it's it's learned it has
no hyper parameters and that's
one thing they point out that once they
have
learned their optimizer it itself
has no hyper parameters it you can you
i mean it can't it's a learned function
right so
there's nothing to search over and
therefore
that's a that's a you know something you
save
so you can see that if it's over this
middle line
the learned optimizer improves over the
other
optimizer for train and test sets
uh in solid and in shaded
you can see for most things there is a
bit of a
movement to the right except in these
you know very
very grid searchy things so if you do
grid search heavily and you have lots of
parameters to tune
it seems you can outperform this thing
but it can outperform things where
you do not grit search at least
on these kinds of tasks which is pretty
cool
um to say it does use more memory
and i don't know exactly if it uses more
time it certainly uses
like five times as much memory as adam i
think they say
yeah time i don't know adam is doing
considerable amount of work as well so
don't underestimate that
compared to like one lstm forward pass
they analyze what their learned
optimizer
remember this is one learned optimizer
out of all these sites they have one
data set they end up with one learned
optimizer
and now they look at it and they feed
this loss function right here
x minus y squared now if you look at the
trajectories of the atom optimizer if
you like start here
it'll go this this way if you start here
it'll go this way of course because this
whole line here
is a a global optimum of this function
so atom seems to be doing something
sensible and in fact i've
i've tried them in a little collab all
of the classic algorithms do this
um however the learned optimizer does
something else
namely it pulls towards zero
zero right it pulls towards kind of the
origin so they claim
that this optimizer has learned
something like
implicit regularization which does make
sense right
this optimizer is optimized
for giving as good of a validation loss
as possible okay now what do we know
especially about small tasks small data
set
small architectures on
on deep learning what do we know about
the validation loss
is that a little bit of regularization
might be a good idea because overfitting
in these regimes is still a problem
so it makes sense that's something that
is
trained to optimize for as low
validation loss as possible will learn
to implicitly regularize the parameters
right i think that's it's it's sensible
and they analyze this right here and
they show that this
optimizer has in fact learned by itself
to kind of pull
the weights towards this point zero
that's one take on it the other take on
it uh could be
it it could be that simply in the tasks
it's given
setting most weights close to zero was
actually just a good idea
per se and maybe the the scale
right here or the shape of the loss
function is too broad for this
and it pulls it towards zero for other
reasons ultimately we can't know it
seems though that the explanation is
somewhat plausible
um i have to say there's one exception
the atom w
so atom w optimizer
will explicitly do the same thing so if
you start with atom w
here let's do that in a different color
it will kind of
um go towards or yeah depending on the
step size it can go like this or it can
go
like this it will pull towards zero
because it also has this kind of
built in so it's cool to see that the
learned optimizer has
learned this though in a chapter
titled understanding optimizer behavior
i would expect honestly uh
something more interesting
than like clearly we have already come
up with
with this in adam w and clearly the
notion that we should
kind of pull weights towards zero and
that might be some sort of a good idea
as a regularization
isn't new to humans right what i would
have
expected um here is that they say wow
our learned optimizer has like
learned kind of a complex but sensible
way to deal with steepness changes in
the landscape
or something like this that that is not
achievable
or not easily achievable by kind of
these classic algorithms it's more
complex but it makes sense
that's what i want a learned optimizer
for i don't want to learn the optimizer
to tell me
well maybe you should like add a bit of
the norm to the loss like gee thanks
so yeah again they don't make claims
about superior behavior of their
optimizer but
still that's kind of what i would expect
from a learned
function um again if you look at the
generalization along different things
you see
the the gray band here is where the up
where the training tasks
lie in terms of the number of hidden
units batch size and data set size
and they say sometimes our learned
optimizer which is in red
generalizes like yeah sometimes it does
but sometimes it just like
screws up completely and
more often than not it seems like
here here okay here it's better but then
here it's
worse so i would not
yet take this off the shelf though i
agree
it has some it has some promising uh
value
lastly they say okay now we've we've
done this on all these small models
let's go
let's go bigger and bigger for them
actually means a small resnet on c410
which is like 14 layer resnet
and a small resnet on resized imagenet
so these are still
small things and i i don't know exactly
why they can only
once they have the optimizer why they
can only feed these maybe because the
lstm
itself also has like an internal memory
constraint when you have to
feed in all of the weights of the
network
however look at this so this is c410
right this is c410 on a resnet
resnet so this is fairly big but
you can see atom and momentum they
overfit
so here is the training loss i'm going
to guess this is the validation loss
they overfit
well the learned optimize wow it doesn't
overfit but
you see so first of all it ends up here
okay ends up here when adam and momentum
were here
their validation loss was here which is
pretty much where this ends up so
better nah and then
you can make two claims you can say this
is because it's whatever implicitly
regularizing but also you can say
this is because it's crap right it like
it doesn't actually manage
at least your optimizer should be able
to get the training loss down
right if if like any optimizer i get it
they say it's implicitly regularizing
but
no like why
like i'd rather have explicit
regularization but have an optimizer
that actually gets the training loss
down as as much as i want it if i run it
longer i don't care about overfitting it
should
peg down the training loss and this one
doesn't do it
i think the explanation here isn't that
it's super duper regularizing here it's
just crap
and yeah again not to say that the paper
is crap but the learned
function they get isn't as good as
atom or momentum here the same thing on
a bigger this is
imagenet on a resnet
on a bigger resnet i believe and you can
see that
yeah you maybe can say that the learned
optimizer is on par with the others
but you see a trend right you see the
trend that this
it gets so when it's small right
small problems the learned optimizer
here outperforms
okay when it's a bit bigger problems the
learned optimizer it still outperforms
invalidation loss
when it's even bigger the learned
optimizer is the same
size right and here you can see if you
grid search you can outperform
the um the learned optimizer three e
minus four
look at that look at that it's like
jackpot um
so
this high suspection is if you go to
even higher problems
right then this learned optimizer will
just get worse and worse and worse
and this is the ultimate dichotomy in
this paper it says
look there are no hyper parameters in
our learned optimizer uh
you you don't have to do grid search
well where can i do grid search
on small problems where can't i do grid
search on big problems
where does this learned optimizer work
on small problems i don't care if i
don't
if i if i can or can't do great search
on small problems i care about
big problems which have fundamentally
different optimization properties
than small models so the last experiment
here is where they take this optimizer
this learned optimizer
and they use it to train itself so they
train it
once and then they you know apply it to
itself like
the analogy is the compiler that can
compile itself
so you can see that yeah at the
beginning
it's kind of faster but then
it kind of flattens out
and you can see that it it
it can't train itself right that's the
answer because
it doesn't matter like this this part
here except in very in limited
circumstances where
you want to like train to okay
performance really fast
it doesn't matter it if it doesn't end
up in the same place
right and you can clearly see here it's
not gonna end up in the same place
i'm gonna show you the full graph in a
second but even from that
you can see that it cannot
train itself it in fact
adam can train it sell it the this
optimizer better than it can train
itself
and this you know that
yeah just take it take that for for what
it is
um they have a full plot like
the longer plot in the appendix right
here
and where is it
here so you know
you decide if this algorithm
can be used to train itself or not
i get it it's pixelated right now it's
gonna load in a second but you can see
all right so the as you said there's
this this
giant um yeah here there you go
this this pseudo code in this paper
right here in the appendix
is supposed to be helpful i guess
um but yeah so what it actually shows
is how is like their variables and how
they interact
and again i find it's correct what they
when they say
there are no hyper parameters once
you've trained the optimizers
but g are there a giant amount of hyper
parameters
in actually training that learned
optimizer
so just deciding which features
go into that and then so you
you have whatever your your your
embeddings
this list like it like okay there are no
hyper parameters in this procedure i get
it i'm
a bit hyperbolic here but there are no
other parameters except for
you know this list the fact that you use
a sine function
um these uh gradient clipping
values right here this um clipping thing
right here the fact that you use a
square root
right here uh whatever you scale that by
this constant right here this thing the
fact that you use log
apps here you can have
all all kinds of things there are not
many hyper parameters
right here but it goes on right the
g norm again we clip by something
that is completely arbitrary
uh you can you can see that the the
architecture oh another clipping value
that is just set to five the
the arbitrariness of how you train this
optimizer itself is is
is riddled with hyper parameters and i
get it the sense is that
this has on has to be done once um
but given the result i feel that
this uh yeah this there's
lots of room and i feel whatever you
input into these whatever rolling
features there are
has is going to have a giant amount of
influence
over the over the
what comes out over the optimizer comes
which is again is something they admit
right so much code
in this yeah okay lastly let's go
to the broader impact statement which i
find to be uh amusing for a
simple reason so the broader impact
statement what is it
supposed to do i i maintain that what
it's supposed to do
is you i i don't agree that these things
have to be in but if you want to put one
in and
the way that the people who require it
frame it is you think about your method
the thing you have suggested and you
think about the ethical
uh societal implications of that and you
really think about the good and the bad
implications of this and my meme it is
the broader impact statement is
technology good technology bad
technology biased
and i say
good bad biased because you want to
think about what's good you want to
think about what's bad
and then there is it's really in fashion
to say that everything is biased and of
course
your model is as a result also biased or
your method or whatnot
this is a a fashion at the moment
um expect this maybe to go away
in a couple of years the other thing
part of the meme is the technology part
so i say technology because
what people usually do is they've just
presented a method
they don't want to trash it right they
like you
you're not going to say my method is
potentially bad what you want to say
is you're going to make it easy for
yourself and say well my method is part
of
machine learning or if you if you have
something for optimizing
gans you say well gans can be used for
good and bad
and are biased right so you you make it
both
easier for yourself and you take
yourself out of the crosshairs by simply
going one or two layers up and the
ultimate layer up of course is just the
statement
technology um so
i intended this to be a meme until i
read
improving technology to do machine
learning
will accelerate its impact for better or
worse
we believe machine learning technologies
will be beneficial to humanity on the
whole
thus improving the ability to optimize
models are moving towards
like literally the meme has become
a reality uh by them explicitly saying
well this is part of technology and
technology can be good or bad
none of none of this is actually about
their
the specifics of their method like in my
mind
if you are seriously doing this you
should think about
what differentiates my particular paper
from other papers and how does that
particular differentiation
manifest good or bad uh
as a consequence like how what are the
consequences of that particular
differentiation
however technology good technology bad
technology
is of course biased so
yeah that's that all right i
i hope this was i i think it's cool work
right this is cool work
and you know google is one of the very
few places where this even
can be done it is certainly it is a
paper that fully admits its limitations
and that's also
extremely cool um and interesting
and it's written very unclear
at times honestly but yeah that was my
commentary i hope you enjoyed this
if you did share it out leave a comment
tell me what you think
including what you think if you have a
different opinion
and i'll see you next time bye